before because I saw this answer in a
lot of pages but I saw some people who
were maybe kinda not sure okay again let
me repeat has extensions students we
need to be sure of that we need to be
like yeah no definitely okay what's
something we could do
you're in a medium you have finished
exam this was early on in the paper
you're looking at it and you're like you
don't know how could you guarantee yeah
thank you that's very helpful if I will
deal with that after we answer this
question what could you try to convince
yourself okay no I'm gonna go with that
fine I'm good
this word I'm going to avoid it as much
as I can in this classroom because
that's not just a sec it's an ambiguous
worth it's ambiguous we will simplify it
in what particular way will we simplify
we've got a better more precise word it
starts with an E I'm going to expand it
okay now we are we've looked at stuff
like this before so slowly know how to
distribute you go X twice you go there
negative for twice and then it should
come out in the wash yeah okay just
another thing I think one of the reasons
why people like mmm not a hundred
percent is because of these negatives
these [ __ ] throw people off quite
frequently okay what I advise you do is
you have something in your back pocket
that you know is like a fact you've
memorized it no question about it if I
asked you for your confidence you'd say
ten out of ten every time my way is this
because it's pretty hard to screw that
one up right now when you've got a
factorization for that in your head you
think oh okay
all positives here for positives here so
if there's a negative here you've
thought of that pair of numbers right we
thought ah negative 4 negative noise
does that mean this is what's possible
as it means - - right so using tables
that you know well to help you with ones
that you don't
as well okay I'm content with that we
give this kind of quadratic their name
because it's coefficient over here is 1
does anyone know the name that we give
to this we call the Monica because one
mono is Latin for one okay so this right
here is a non monic quadratic now there
are at least three different ways that
we could factorize describe would anyone
like to not have to do it but anyone
like to suggest for me yeah yeah okay so
again let me give you some language for
this right because we need to be more
precise then do the thing and the other
thing with them don't do that the
coefficient of x squared multiplied that
by the constant term that gives you 24
what I'll do that okay so I want to find
factors of 24 okay now we've already
established see what I did there
there's lots of factors of 24 which one
of these do you want you want this one
why that one what makes you go okay
because they're related to the
coefficient of x okay so now I've chosen
two numbers what are you gonna do with
them
so I haven't said anything yet we've had
a lot of good contributions very bad for
it but some people quit standing back
what am I gonna do with ain't afraid I
can't good now let's just pause there
for a second
do you remember I said to you there's at
least three ways we could do this okay
the first way you've already abandoned
that's quadratic formula I'm glad you'll
bend and it goes long inappropriate and
we don't need it okay so you could have
done you could have done the quadratic
formula okay we're doing it a different
way now what we're doing is what we call
gripping you'll see why it's called
creeping in a second now how many of you
went to proving this is what the next
line looks like something like I think
this is what you suggested something
like that who would have done that who
took that next step
hands up yeah okay hands down who would
have done something else with the egg in
the three anyone okay
interesting I want to show you another
way to do it if we're here now what
would you like me to do next now you can
see why it's called grouping right so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
group together pairs of terms these guys
and these guys okay what happens when I
group them what will I do with the
group's I will because the whole things
aren't factorizing I'll look for a
common factor here and then I'll look
for a common factor here what's the
first one it's 2x isn't it so let's
write this thing up
yes what's now yeah you happy with that
what about the second pin it's just a
three which leaves you with and if you
did it right it should match yes okay so
now already one of the things I really
like about this method is that it's kind
of you can't screw it up if you've
picked the right numbers for example see
this X is 3 X what would happen if you
did it the other way round the answer is
not really
anything at all watch if you've got this
line of work and you're just on the side
here maybe another color if you've got
it this is really very important we
distinguish between methods in
mathematics ones that are more resilient
to error and ones that are less
resilient right some methods you've got
to get everything exactly lined up
otherwise you're stuffed
other methods they kind of have a little
bit of gear and if you do something at
the beginning that maybe wasn't what you
were supposed to do it still sort of
comes out what can I do here how about
us do I think all I've got is just an X
oh do you see what's happening you see
what's happening don't you
what's the next factor which leaves you
with and I don't need to feed do i okay
that's nice that's nice now I said I was
going to show you one other way you
don't have to use this way you don't
even have to like it
but it's really important that you've
got lots of tools up in your tool belt
because different problems can be
students of different methods okay I'm
going to take the eight in the three I'm
going to do something slightly different
I have some space instead of doing what
you've done okay I'm going to write this
okay I don't know if any of you've seen
something like this before now what have
I done I know at the front here I wanted
to x squared by the end of this okay so
I've got the 2x and the 2x I know it's
going to appear somewhere I just don't
know where it's gonna be so I put it in
both spots but of course 2x times 2x and
2x fit does not make right so that's why
I divide by 2 you see that you see
that's been compensating okay now what
am I gonna do with my eight my three I'm
just gonna put them in anywhere I like
see that and now what can I do
do you see if I've done it right if I
chosen my a my three correctly then
these two should go into either this one
or this one or in more complicated
examples they might even divide a bit by
both right suppose it's not moves like
say six you could invite this one by 2
and this one by three if it was
appropriate based on the ones okay
instead I just divide this one which
leaves you with the same factorization
we got the other two times